Netflix's new sci-fi movie the titan
star Sam Worthington and Taylor
Schilling from oranges new black I was
actually really enjoying the beginning
of this movie had me very interested
with a cool concept of speeding up
evolution to save mankind to live on
another moon which was the Titan moon
but I thought the movie took a tumble
here once Sam Worthington character and
the girl became full-on Titans because
they had to make them super brain-dead
which was annoying to me especially
because when he was swimming in the pool
and the other Titan comes over she
killed her husband for some reason I
didn't understand that they'd even show
her kind of freaked out at all and then
she tries to kill these soldiers and
then they kill her and sam worthington
jumps to her defense
but then kills all these soldiers so
then I didn't like him anymore there was
no point of him doing that why did he do
that even the wife knew is our own thing
at the moment but they kind of just
shake that off cuz he's character in
real life would never do that and he
didn't have enough rage to explain him
just becoming a dummy all of a sudden
I'm gonna say some crazy here but I
agreed with the villain in this movie I
think he deserves the credit for getting
this Titan to another planet to save the
human race this was his idea no one
believed in him he said people were
gonna die and that maybe one comes out
of it and it did and he should get
credit for it I mean there's points tell
her shillings character didn't want I'm
doing it anymore so why was he so hated
at the end they all knew what they were
signing up for the guy got no love I
didn't agree with Taylor shillings
character choice anything it made sense
do not take her husband out of suffering
when she switched the antidotes and just
gave him rage to again kill a bunch of
soldiers that are just doing their job
so again I may may not like him even
more or her why not put him out of his
misery all these memories let him finish
his job without missing them because I'm
sure he's a go on this planet and miss
his family so it was selfish to me on
her part she didn't want him to forget
her it was a slow predictable movie it
really is if you sum it up just a long
movie with the mutation process like if
you just watch Overeem changing
Wolverine in x-men for the whole movie
that's what you're getting here it
wasn't any great action sequences they
were quick especially for a high budget
movie you gotta give us a little more
than that and it's 2048 why are there
land rovers still around and for
discoveries they really have to put
these product placements in this
it's too far in the future to get away
with that you got to make them look more
futuristic but the actors were great
Taylor Schilling was great this really
was her movie Sam Worthington was great
as well and for a Netflix movie it's
good it's not horrible
it wasn't cheesy wasn't over the top
it's just kind of there
so I'm gonna give it a 7 mostly because
of its lackluster Emmys but I did like
the beginning Netflix movies are
starting to get the vibe of how to make
a solid movie we're getting that
patience people humble with your quick
thoughts on the Titan I responded
everybody please subscribe i review
bunch of movies TV shows celebrity
interviews and they're all fast quick so
you don't want to miss those and please
keep coming back